elle la queue dans les transports les
italiens reprennent depuis ce lundi
leurs vieilles habitudes bus métro
boulot le port du masque est exigée mais
une impression domine le soulagement
c'était un sentiment positif d'aller au
travail ce matin après deux mois à la
maison c'était agréable
il ya toujours un peu de peur mais j'ai
été rassuré par ce que j'ai vu dans le
métro tout le monde porter des masques
commençons la phase 2 de manière
positive
nous devrons être forts et capables de
nous adapter à cette situation pour
revenir le plus rapidement possible à
une vie normale
[Musique]
l'italie est donc entré dans la deuxième
partie de son déconfinement 4,4 millions
de personnes sont attendues sur les
chantiers dans les bureaux les usines ou
encore les boutiques stefano par exemple
a rouvert sa papeterie
non sans quelques inquiétudes ce plan
pour lever des impôts et taxes
je dois tout désinfecter j'ai déjà des
masques les clients doivent entrer dans
le magasin en portant un masque et
respecter une distance de sécurité
si j'y arrive j'achèterai du gel
désinfectant pour les mains le
gouvernement nous a donné 600 euros
d'argent de poche
il aurait pu faire plus c'est sûr mais
c'est mieux que rien avant une
réouverture complète le 1er juin les
bars et les restaurants proposent dès
aujourd'hui des plans emporté un bol
d'air frais pour des italiens autoriser
de nouveau à se promener et à faire de
l'exercice à l'extérieur nous sommes
heureux parce qu'enfin aujourd'hui ils
ont rouvert la villa borghèse et après
l'avoir fermé pendant un mois et demi
même si évidemment ma fille a été déçu
de trouver l'accès au terrain de jeu
complètement interdite un seul mot
d'ordre dans le pays distant session
sociale les forces de l'ordre sont très
présents dans les rues et lieux de
transport
il est désormais possible de rendre
visite à ses proches à condition qu'ils
vivent dans la même région une
attestation est toujours de rigueur pour
justifier ses déplacements une troisième
phase est attendu le 18 mai avec
notamment la réouverture des commerces
mais aussi des bibis
au tec des musées et des lieux culturels